turning now to a story about a police
officer who uses poetry to explore his
complicated feelings about duty and
identity i spoke with my friend officer
sean bland of the inglewood new jersey
police department officer bland is a
24-year veteran of the force and also a
poet with the book of his own poems
coming out next year we discuss what
it's like being a black police officer
in america and also what he believes
needs to change and how putting his
feelings on paper helps him heal
have you
walked outside your door and thought to
yourself i could die today
yeah
yeah i i have have you been in shootouts
before one
what was that like it's uh very surreal
uh things slow down i remember not being
afraid
because there was no time for emotion
it was just time to react and to live
and to survive
reality set in yeah and i was like
saying oh that was you know we almost
didn't make it englewood police veteran
sean bland still carries with him the
emotions brought on by that encounter 20
years ago in the abyss i embrace death
my disease these days he channels those
emotions through a pen and a pad put
down my shovel stop digging my ditch
desire for dying no longer i itch and
how has poetry served as an outlet for
you as a person and a cop well as a
person it's been an outlet an emotional
release being a cop is not like being an
accountant
your experiences what you experience
from day to day those experiences pile
up like this in real time if those
experiences build up without you being
able to interpret them and without you
being able to resolve them for yourself
you're going to overload how does being
a police officer
affect your mental health to be quite
honest man i got diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder years ago
so i go to counseling man you know i go
to therapy to help me manage
because
i need to be well
bland a husband and father of two wrote
monster with his children in mind i'm
trying to survive in america defenseless
to be black a poem that tackles the
intersection of his identity as an
african-american and a cop in america my
son my daughter inherited my fear
i can't promise their safety but they
listen they hear
and then you went on my children also
american but not yet free
framed at conception america's public
enemy
usually when uh
black father is talking to their kids
about being black in america
they don't speak from a perspective of
being a police officer what was it like
when you're talking to
your kids about
being young and being black
and possibly being looked at as a
monster that's a heavy conversation
that's a conversation that my
counterpart in america does not have
with his children to have a conversation
with your son to say hey listen man you
have to carry yourself a certain way
you're 15 years old you're put together
like a man people are gonna be a little
threatened by that
i remember calling you when i was ready
to have that conversation with my son
that's right nate and nehemiah
and
you gave me a whole checklist
he said if they're driving
turn down the car radio
roll down the windows put the light on
hands at 10 and two absolutely because
policemen we're looking for certain
markers if you do something to arouse
them so that their
antennas go up it's gonna be very hard
for you to do anything next to make
those antennas go down
[Applause]
the murder of george floyd by convicted
ex-police officer derek shovin
recharged the demand for police reform i
got to ask you straight up
do you believe that defunding the police
is a good idea i absolutely do not
i think that uh it needs to be harder to
become a cop
i think that
the standards need to go way
up
i think that the training should be
longer i think that uh
the background checks should be more
thorough but i don't think the funding
the police is the answer man but
to people who are on the outside looking
in
that doesn't satisfy i've given a lot of
thought to this i truly believe that any
time a police officer is involved in a
gun related issue a shooting a death of
any civilian i truly believe that the
federal government should be the
investigators i mean law enforcement
works when you're actually enforcing the
law that's when it works
well said now that phrase defund the
police has become politically charged
and does not mean disband police
departments instead some communities are
pushing to recalib reallocate those
funds and resources to other forms of
public safety and community support
officer bland told us that we need to
bridge that gap between police and the
communities that they serve um you know
and he makes a valid point you know he
spoke about the men and women that serve
these communities and how we need to
create more initiatives so that
relationship between the police in those
communities aren't so strained yeah the
messaging on defund the police is has
not been helpful and i love what i love
what your friend said that law
enforcement works when we actually
enforce the law i also like sean bland
yes i also like that he said that he
gets therapy nade yeah i think that's
such an important message to send that
when you're dealing with something
especially for black men in particular
yeah the fact that he could speak about
it so candidly and that it has helped
him he seems like a good man and we need
more good men and women going into law
enforcement yeah and so that may not be
defund the police it could be quite the
opposite paying a wage and providing the
training to make officers as get the
best people and then make them their
best selves yeah make it harder to
become a he said a lot of good
stuff and he said make it harder yes the
requirements of becoming a police
officer and then maintaining that badge
which also using those funds to help
with the mental health and making sure
they're in the right state of mind while
they go out there to protect and serve
us has he helped you you seem to have a
relationship yeah i call him whenever i
have an issue wherever i have a question
he's the guy that i lean on he's he's
more than a friend he's like a brother
does he help you get out of speeding
tickets no
i just don't speak okay